con la Selección del Jurado en la corte
del distrito de Columbia acá en
Washington empezó el juicio en contra de
Stuart roads el líder del grupo armado
ufkipers y otros cuatro integrantes más
de esta organización en el juicio que
durará cerca de 6 semanas estos cinco
integrantes son acusados de Conspiración
sediciosa Es decir de planear el uso de
la fuerza para evitar la transferencia
de poder durante el proceso de
certificación del voto electoral el 6 de
enero del 2021 para que el crimen de
Conspiración sediciosa se compruebe se
necesita que los fiscales demuestren que
se acordó entre dos o más personas el
uso de la fuerza para desconocer la
autoridad de un gobierno o devorar la
ejecución de una ley y hallarse
culpables Entonces estos militantes
podrían pagar hasta 20 años de cárcel
según el New York Times los armaron
brigadas de respuesta inmediata en
Arlington en Virginia ciudad limítrofe
con Washington desde donde se puede
portar armas y estaban listos para
llevar a cabo operaciones militares en
respuesta se espera que el abogado de
los militantes argumente que esta
milicia solo estaba esperando órdenes de
Donald Trump y que este invocará el acta
de insurrección que les habría permitido
el uso de la fuerza al grupo para
defender al gobierno de Trump sin
embargo Fiscales argumentan que el acta
de insurrección no le permite a un
presidente Llamar a grupos armados
privados en los próximos meses en todo
caso se espera que empiece el juicio
contra otras milicias que participaron
en la toma al